-Well, you guys, this is huge.
Earlier today, House Democrats
unveiled the official
articles of impeachment
against President Trump,
which the media called giant
historic, and a very big deal.
That's right -- The impeachmen
has now reached
Baby Yoda status.
[ Laughter ]
As she announced the charges
against Trump,
Nancy Pelosi called it
a solemn day.
Yeah, you could barely tell sh
was flossing behind the podium
[ Laughter ]
"Charges against the president
are very grave.
Very serious.
Solemn day."
[ Cheers and applause ]
At the press conference,
Adam Schiff said for Congress,
the impeachment
is not a matter of facts.
It is rather a question of duty.
Trump heard that and was like,
"Hey, speaking of
question of duty,
how many times do you flush?
I'm up to the mid teens."
Meanwhile, committee chairma
Jerry Nadler
said Trump consistently
puts himself above the country
And in response,
Trump accused Nadler
of consistently putting
his pants above his nipples.
[ Laughter ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
Nadler then said,
"We must be clear.
No one, not even the president
is above the law."
Yeah, it's strange,
but it seemed like Nadler
kept using Steven Seagal movie
to explain the impeachment
First, he said, "Not even
the president is above the law."
Then he said, "Trump has lef
our democracy under siege,
and that we made
a poor executive decision.
And it's Congress' job
to be out for justice.
And finally, Nadler said
that even though Trump's hai
is red on top,
there's also a fire down below
[ Laughter ]
He kept doing it.
-There you go.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-While the Democrats
were unveiling
their articles of impeachmen
against Trump,
there was a photo taken
at the press conference.
Take a look at this.
Yeah, and you can kind of tell
what everyone is thinking.
For instance,
Nancy Pelosi is thinking,
"Remember,
serious on the outside,
Christmas morning
on the inside."
[ Laughter ]
Carolyn Maloney is thinking,
"I think those five shots
of Jaeger were a bad idea.
Here, you could tell
Eliot Engel is thinking,
"I think there's some soup
in my mustache.
Better get it real quick."
Also, Jerry Nadler is thinking
"When does a tie get so wide
that it's considered a scarf?"
[ Laughter ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
Finally, the painting of
George Washington is thinking,
"I shouldn't have gotten my wife
a Peloton for Christmas."
[ Laughter,
cheers and applause ]
Just got to --
-Don't do it.
-After the press conference,
a reporter on MSNBC
was trying to break down
the articles of impeachmen
at the Capitol
but had some competition.
Take a look at this.
-Walk us through
these two specific
articles of impeachment.
[ Choir singing ]
-Yeah, reporting from
the halls of Congress,
which, as you can hear,
are filled with the sounds
of holiday cheer.
So let's just go with it.
Going through
this short document,
there's two things that they
were trying to demonstrate here.
-Wow.
Is Nancy Pelosi
in a good mood or what?
I mean, like --
♪♪ Dah who doraze, yahoo oray
Some 2020 news.
I saw that Democratic candidates
have until Thursday
to qualify for the next debate
Some of them
are getting very desperate
Today, Cory Booker
tried to gain support
by wearing a Bernie Sanders wig.
I thought that was odd.
[ Laughter ]
Well, this is a big deal.
I saw that Russia
has been banned
from competing
in the 2020 Olympics
due to a doping scandal.
Of course they're disappointed
so to cheer up the athletes,
Russia has decided to hold
its very own Olympics,
and the events
are pretty interesting.
For example, you can compete
in the 100-meter dash from bear.
You can also compete
in the Chernobyl marathon.
[ Audience groans ]
And finally,
shirtless horseback riding
It's going to be
very interesting.
-Wow.
-Very interesting.
-Can't wait.
-You guys see this?
I saw that a Bible-themed
video game is coming out.
People are very excited
about this.
It allows you to perform
miracles as Jesus.
We actually have a clip
of the game.
This is the real game.
You can -- So you can --
This is the game.
So apparently,
they've updated it
so you can perform
some more modern miracles.
Like putting a duvet
on a comforter
in less than 10 minutes.
Or turning water
into White Claw.
Or miracles like eating
a Nature Valley granola ba
without getting oat gravel
all on your keyboard.
And, of course, knowing whethe
to swipe or insert the chi
on the first try.
[ Laughter,
cheers and applause ]
No. Insert?
-Not yet.
-Swipe?
-And finally, I saw that the CEO
of Away luggage is stepping down
and she's being replaced wit
an executive from Lululemon.
The guy from Lululemon
isn't sure if it's a great fit
but he's going to squeeze
himself in there anyway.
We have a great show.